it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's going on everybody welcome
to movie fights hashtag movie fights
live you know this show slaps that's an
insider if you were watching on last
week what a balun a ssin percival in the
house we got a great show for you today
we're gonna go venture into the Potter
verse and we got some awesome fighters
right here first you know him he's the
host of the nerd goat podcast and he's
on sju every week what I bet Grier Wow
[Applause]
ba Baracus somebody gave me some milk
and then I woke up here doing this Oh
usually that happened when the a-team
had to put ba Baracus on a plane yeah
yeah right on no thanks for being here
man okay don't be playin too afraid to
fly yeah next he's a super funny dude
and he's one of the writers of honest
trailers you know for sju otherwise
Joestar I have her again so what'd you
have for breakfast oh man I had a very
healthy smoothie awesome glad to hear it
very good and she's making her regular
movie fights debut is that correct
very exciting you saw her in the debut
death match and she's here to bring the
pain
Vanessa [ __ ] Vanessa and what's that
oh yeah M ETH OD Vanessa yeah thanks for
being here excited to have you and yeah
let's uh let's see what goes down and
keeping score and making sure everything
runs according to plan
is going to be myself and rad biz rad
biz Daniel Rafferty
business hard to do a Ford Fusion for
the two of ya could only have one Tom
Cruise and Katie Holmes the Tomcat
business business that's our acting name
and I'm excited yeah your any other
facts today correct sir I'm gonna be
checking the facts for mr. dan Marla's a
little under the weather give him some
love Edie takes a lot to start off the
show with an a-team reference so I'm
really excited for today also if you
haven't already check out Billie
businesses really sharp podcast hotcakes
with Billy biz
yeah the newest episode is this lovely
over oh yeah about movies good touch
Danielle so you are the conduit or the
people please explain to us what's
happening I am I am the voice of the
people there are many polls that will
happen throughout the night a lot of
them on the hash tag movie fights live
on Twitter we do encourage you to go on
movie fights live talk about give us
alternate theories means whatever you
have I will be picking out some of the
best ones but the way this works is
there will be a poll every round and
will go up once the fighters have given
their initial arguments that poll the
one that counts is the one on YouTube if
you have any questions click down in the
description below or ask questions in
the chat we would be more than happy to
help you figure it out and that will be
the tiebreaker just in case of it the
other two other two gentlemen can't
figure it out oh hell yeah which is
often the case okay and then we'll find
ourselves in a great moment in sports so
just a replay of how the game goes it's
a best-of-seven player needs four points
to win after three rounds to top two
players will go into a speed round and
it's anybody's game after that y'all
ready for this
[Music]
yeah who doesn't love summer jock jams
almost as good as MTV's party to go yeah
buddy yeah all right so here we are with
question number one of fantastic beasts
to crimes Grindelwald opens this week we
ask you who is the best character in the
entire Harry Potter Wizarding World
movie franchise this is encompasses
everything
wow what a question okay and we're gonna
start with player number one and grier
okay well my pick is Ron Weasley and and
this is the thing Ron Weasley
I don't want to blow my opening
statements on stupid jokes okay but damn
he's like a regular guy amongst these
wizards everyone knows that I hate magic
and this this I am Superman in a
kryptonite palace right now talking
about magic stuff for a while you know I
mean I just I'm my skin's burning and
Lex Luthor's wedding somewhere you don't
I mean I can't hear as good as I used to
you know I mean it's weird I'm get Sam
but I will say amongst all these
characters Ron Weasley is my man he's
always down to eat he gets the girl in
the end it sounds like me already and
and he's poor boom another one you know
I can relate and last but not least
Ron Weasley knows the history of the
Weasleys he knows that Weasley's died in
the service of this larger magic story
and he still chooses to participate
which means he's a brave ass dude along
with those other cool traits I've
mentioned so elaborate later but my pick
is Ron Weasley he's the man all right
and opening up with Ron Weasley Joestar
who you got I'm going rogue how oh I'm
going with a muggle whoo or should I say
a nomad the best character in The Wizard
World franchise is jacob kowalski dan
Fogle's Jacob Kowalski from fantastic
beasts and where to find them
the best part of fantastic beasts and
where to find them maybe the only good
part
that's a debate for another show I came
out of that movie just absolutely loving
Jacob Kol Jacob Kowalski I think a key
thing in the Harry Potter movies was
Daniel Radcliffe's Harry Potter sort of
serving as this like wide-eyed little
little kid just amazed by everything
that he was seeing the first two years
in Hogwarts but then you know he hit the
middle school portion of the Wizarding
World and just became this like jaded
little kid that was always shouting
about how everyone was out to get him
and puberty and girls and blah blah blah
and he got really he turned into a real
My Chemical Romance kind of bummer
whereas Jacob a Kowalski brings back
that connection for the audience into
the Wizarding World he reminds us in
every frame in every face in in his
performance that he makes in his
performance that this is a really
incredible elevated world he's just
seeing things left and right that
constantly astonished him he is not only
just sort of your your your muggle guide
to the world but he's a really well
fleshed out character he's this guy
that's down on his luck he's a baker
that's trying to do his best that's
trying to change his own life and step
up and do better and when he's at his
lowest when he's been sort of denied his
future basically by the bank that's when
he steps into this larger world with
Newt Scamander and that's just a really
cool place to start the character arc
and by the end of that you've traveled
with him for so long what he had to step
into that weird amnesia reign it's like
honestly it's like a very like
heartbreaking very sad moment that
really sticks with you so I'm gonna go
Jacob Kowalski Kowalski from Joestar
Vanessa talked to us I'm gonna go with
probably the best Dark Arts teacher
Hogwarts has ever had Remus Lupin he's
my absolute favorite while most of the
professor's have their faults I mean
name a teacher in the Harry Potter
universe that did it why he was not only
the best teacher that they ever had like
he defended Neville in front of Snape
which most professors didn't even want
to do but also he's a big linchpin and
who Harry becomes as an adult he taught
him his Patronus spell he was the kind
of
he was the most level-headed he was such
a loyal friend that his friends would
like taught themselves how to become
animals just to hang out with him when
he was a werewolf most people won't even
drive me to the airport that's how much
they loved and like you could even use
the argument like sure he almost debated
his child at one point but she didn't
and he died for his kid he died to give
his kid a better world he made a
sacrifice that most people in me like
anybody that was a name now hasn't made
and he's witty he always has candy he's
fantastic all right there you have it
three very different choices fight it
out you guys I want to talk first on
this candy situation because I
understand that that's important you
know it's a-you know he's got the
chocolate it's available knows how to
talk to people
Jacobs a baker like Jacobs always got a
sweet treat ready to go so I feel like
you know in that battle of desserts
you know Jacobs just really got lupine
right up again I was the one who told
Harry about the chocolate frogs that
jump run Beasley spends all of the books
and all of the movies whining about oh I
have such a big stupid family to an
orphan yeah I'm like oh man it sucks I
have a mom that loves siblings around
parents were killed
Skeletor terrors to Clair namely a 13
year old person who's not a narcissist
okay these kids bastards all right and
he's just one of the bastards because
there's a lot of characters in there
that are very lofty and I've been had
their rough edges hewn off in the movies
I think it's like Hermione and Harry
even to a certain scent Ron is left
holding a bunch of baggage from some
stuff he didn't even do in the books I
think the main lead the baggage that Ron
hangs on to is a suitcase full of
exposition that he just sort of doles
out every now and then look this is how
wizard clocks work and that's like his
only role in the story well guess how
you get on the train also I'm gonna make
Hermione crying again
all the bunch of no magic as bombs and
and werewolves they would we wouldn't
get the damn information that's the cool
thing is that it's not all muggles and
no matches there's this one specific
standout guy he's like the only positive
view of the muggle world we have in the
whole franchise otherwise it's just the
dirt sleaze being like getting back in
the staircase boy but this guy you uh he
gives people like this he's he's like
you talk back through the adventure Joe
people who are like hey could you help
with this could you do this could you
help with that he says yeah you know
what and yeah I will even though it's
crazy to him like because it's the right
thing to do because he has good
instincts about who he should trust and
who should follow and you know that's
why I think
Queeny is immediately smitten with him
because you know she sees in people's
heads and she sees sort of this guy in
history like scarves
come on man come on tea is great but as
you said he's a great part of like a
not-so-great movie that's like saying
the best part of a good meal is an
after-dinner mint but that's a dope
though I mean he's not he's not the
great Ron Weasley has won a came up with
the Basma idea to destroy the Horcruxes
am i saying these words right Larry
about his name being in the Goblet of
Fire he tends to cop out pretty easily
do the right thing a lot of characters
in fiction say the wrong thing to the
hero to bring out the heroes here onus I
question Ed's ability to to label
someone joyful and awesome and cool and
a Wizarding
so much I can't you should be down with
Jacob Kowalski man he's just this normal
ass dude that just wants to bake
doughnuts
that gets dumped into character virtues
my man Ron sacrificed himself on the
chess obstacle he chose the night and I
think a night is a very good way to talk
about Ron because Ron is not he doesn't
have all the powers of the Queen or the
or the or the or the bishop and all that
jazz he's just a regular knight he can
move in ELLs maybe he can move these
ELLs and he lead makes that'd be enough
and he helps Harry Potter to do all this
different accompanies adventures where
as your teacher come on man he's like
he's like 52 pages I don't know what I
can Paulo fight against run Ron's the
main guy well I did did he teach Harry
had a cast of attorneys that did a lot
of things that Ron did through the books
that I could not stomach
who's the dopest uncle that swoops in
does some cool [ __ ] for your kid after
Christmas Christmas and then swoops out
Lupin would absolutely be the answer he
is that dope uncle but like Santa Claus
he couldn't be more pages because he did
make the ultimate sacrifice of his life
well Ron is always in constant fear of
doing that he's always ready to die he
could have died in the chest obstacle he
could have died a bunch of times and his
brothers and his brothers have died
people in the wizzy family died in these
ventures as I stated in my opening
statement he knows the Dewey's these
aren't the main guys his robe is wacky
got holes in it he reminds me what I
want you know to school it was wack but
he still goes and he still learns this
stuff because he knows he's integral to
the adventures
whereas Lupin is like this afterthought
character with fur on him and I just I
don't know why he's standing with my boy
the redhead genius I mean the redhead
workman well like Wayman there are the
redheads in their family that didn't
whine as much as Ron does cuz Ron spends
a significant time whining like when
they gave no one like Jenni's not
whining what Ron whined the whole time
they were on the run as if they weren't
like as if they were on some kind of
like vacation or something as if you
didn't know what he had signed up for
Ron knows what he signed up for
who's that guy who comes to a party and
moans the whole time about how it's
weird phantasm hairy and weird phantasm
remaining made out in front of Ron he
deserved that he had that come on kill
my you troll is a whiny little jerk yeah
I know I fear and just because he didn't
I don't want it to be held against him
that he didn't die I don't need that
that's terrible is that he doesn't even
he's so new to this like he's not even
like oh let's what are we gonna do he's
like what the hell is this do you need
my help to deal which also doesn't
understand enough about the adventure to
know how much danger he is and whereas
ron has family history that says all
this jazz you're about to embark on is
super dangerous and he faces down his
main fear he scared spiders he has a
face down a big giant ass spider go
ahead and roll this into your final
thoughts indiana jones ian the way that
this guy faces his fears and and and
again he understands unlike your
character he understands what he's into
he's not just some bunch of it's not a
light show it doesn't think he's not a
Pink Floyd show alright that he's
tripped in half the time he knows that
this is real and this is dangerous and
he still per season his adventure and
again he is probably one of the second
most maybe third most important
character in the whole thing besides
Hermione and Harry he's there for all
the key stuff I don't see how I can lose
to it a werewolf and and a bomb don't do
no magic I just don't see how I can lose
this one man all right Joe star I think
there's a there's something to be said
with these characters and what they do
was sort of the characters around them I
think if you take the trio of I don't
know why I'm talking like coin a speed
around right now I think if you if you
take the characters of Harry and
Hermione and you lose Ron I think you
lose a couple of jokes everyone's like
Ron but I don't think you lose any
anything concrete you don't lose any
clue whereas I think Jacob makes Newt
more approachable and more human you
care about Newt more because Jacob has
decided to care about him I think he
makes a Queenie more interesting I think
he makes his he elevates his circle
whereas I don't think that Ron Weasley
does and I think you need a really
strong anchor into these weird worlds to
guide you and then just talking about
vocals performances Jakob Kowalski he
makes every frame of performance in that
first fantastic beast movie count
justjust the Wonder in his eyes
everything he does the physical comedy
he sort of applies this sort of like
light subtle like Laurel and Hardy sort
of Three Stooges like physical comedy
that really provides some really cool
levity as they're like searching for
these beasts or they're searching for
credence or whatever I just think he's
he's a great character and the best out
of the three thanks Jo Vanessa I think
Lupin is such a lynchpin for the man
that Harry becomes he provides so much
insight to a life that he didn't have
any of the answers to and to a family
that he didn't feel a connection to not
only that but it's not about how much
the character appears but it's how much
happens because of them and in his short
time both in the book and his portrayal
in the movie he makes you fall in love
with him he makes his absence hurt
because of how much you fall for him and
I don't I don't think double-doors army
would exist without Harry's interactions
with Lupin Thank You Vanessa time look
what's happening in the fact it might as
well have been in another language no
idea what anyone was saying I'm sure
today but sounded pretty argumentative
though I could not vouch for the for the
narcissism of thirteen-year-olds other
than my own personal experience yes all
right Thank You Billy for not checking
any facts
I mean on paper it's it's Ron Weasley
but it's not on paper it's in right here
off paper and attentional real light and
at our half circle ring damn there was
good arguments from all y'all and Joe
you made a great argument for a
character that was only in one movie
Vanessa you made it you made Loomis a
loop in a player and this in a match he
shouldn't have been and weasly I think
you sold him to us what's he's flawed
but he also steps up when it counts
Wow but the one that I I feel like I
heard the least take downs of and the
one that I feel just had the strongest
through-line of the argument and the
biggest connection to the world in the
story that came from for my money it
came from Vanessa and I got to go with a
Remus Lupin yeah and yeah and they
really double-teamed you there's a lady
with steel chairs on the ladders they
took the ring bell and knock you upside
the head and it was hard to recover from
hey your plus/minus is gonna be
influenced if you're on the floor more
right on okay so one one for Vanessa in
my book yeah look I only had the
arguments to go off of this around
really like it's very strange
what you guys chose like why would you
not choose Harry Potter like that's a
nice all of you reference how your
character faced another character
it's so strange to me I could feel your
soul dying the entire time the passion
that you had while just slowly dying
it's commendable but not enough to win
my vote down to Joe and Vanessa Joe you
almost had me but you kind of you kind
of stepped on your own foot at the very
beginning because you said so much like
this character helps the main character
and helps us be a better movie but you
set off the bat this isn't a good movie
so he can't help that much so on that
note I just sorry I have to give it to
Vanessa Vanessa takes the point I'm sure
I'd love to hear the poll and then I'm
sure the Internet has opinions on
characters we've got Remus Lupin
everybody percent jacob Kowalski at 18
percent Ron Weasley why not this person
why didn't you Bob sure so but two of
the comments I really liked on Twitter
and Jack underscore D underscored
Mannheim said maybe not the best but my
favorite has always been Dudley Dursley
he becomes what is essentially
institutionalized racism on his own he
sees the good person his cousin is and
lets go of his prejudices that is an
incredible feat for a teenager and then
at mcgann gator 24 he's not my favorite
character but I will argue that Neville
Longbottom is the best Harry Potter
character he is faithful and loyal more
than anyone he is very skilled in magic
once he becomes confident and a
reflection that you grow as a person
oh those are two ballots for Twitter
yeah thoughtful tweets I like movie
fights live hashtag there are really
good well-thought-out arguments on there
and I don't get to highlight everyone
and I wish I could write on thank you
good choices Danielle and yeah I'm happy
not just that Remus Lupin won but I
love that actor David Thewlis and a few
I'll just give you a quick movie
recommendation
there's our dark philosophical journey
of a movie called naked directed by Mike
Lee starring David Thewlis it's great
check it out if you like dark
philosophical journey he's amazing at
big mouths oh yeah yeah right on all
right it's won over Nessa these fellows
are looking to get on the board with
question numero dos we talked about this
on sju this week and now we want to
fight about it movie don't you dare
touch these following movies and we're
gonna start with mr. Joestar
the answer is big trouble a little China
I think that's what I put that's what
yes it's a reason it in Saturday for a
second I and I didn't what you guys
think I was going rogue this is a John
Carpenter masterpiece that is a parody
and send-up of the 80s blockbusters that
were getting really big at the time the
studio themselves thought they were
getting this giant action romp where'd
basically a Clint Eastwood character was
just gonna beat up a bunch of kung-fu
guys and OH
little did they know what John Carpenter
and Kurt Russell were sending to them
just an amazing satire of America thinks
it knows it all when really we're all
just kind of just these clueless sort of
morons bumbling around these much
smarter people and completely out of our
depth this is this is a movie that can't
be remade it's it's a perfect alchemy of
cast and performance and time you know
John Carpenter was really ahead of his
time and I think even back then he sort
of saw the weird fantasy fetish
fetishization of Asian cultures in
Hollywood and I think big trouble is
like a really strong riff on that with
just how over-the-top and goofy it is
with David lo pan literally like playing
video game magic against Victor Wong
Victor Wong rest in peace
speaking of Victor Wong as age
and you can't do a picture of a little
China movie without the incredible
mentor character of egg Chen Victor Wong
who was also the grandfather and three
ninjas he has left his mortal coil and
therefore as far as I'm concerned he's
more important to this franchise than
Kurt Russell in a lot of ways and you
just can't do it
I think Hollywood would just turn this
into a big silly special effects budget
thing I don't think the rock who's been
rumored to attach to a remake has the
he's great and super charismatic but I
don't think he can walk that subtle line
of this is ridiculous that Kurt Russell
could Thank You Joestar Big Trouble of
China Vanessa I'm going with Monty
Python and the Holy Grail that's
something that absolutely can't be
remade because you can't do it without
the titular Monty Python sketch troupe
and Monty Python doesn't really do
things everything they do is like a
mandala it's beautiful and intricate and
it's done once and it's meant to be
enjoyed and then it's swept away and
never done again so that it can build on
it at a later point the best parts about
Monty Python happened out of a deficit
of a budget like the infamous coconut
joke happened because they had to
because they couldn't afford horses and
that kind of inventiveness comes from
when you don't really have a budget and
nobody's really looking at you so you
can get really weird and interesting
about it the kind of people that would
remake Monty Python and the Holy Grail
aren't gonna make good choices try and
imagine Seth Rogen laughing through the
Knights who say snake situation like the
kind of person that would want to remake
Monty Python the Holy Grail is probably
gonna put like a lethargic Donnie Johnny
Depp role into the it's not gonna work
it's lightning in a bottle like it
remaking it graphics isn't gonna make it
better it works because it was the first
thing like it that existed Thank You
Vanessa
ed Grier I mean these are all great
choices I need to preface my argument by
saying that these are all great choices
and they're all very unique motion
pictures but my choice is pulp fiction
and it's it Jo talked about an alchemy
of time-space and cast and you cannot
make pulp fiction now you can't do it
the script doesn't get
the the the development person grabs
that script and throws it in the trash
first off and second off it's it's one
of these things where it can't be
improved by president so-called present
technology there isn't anything that
could be done to make it more than what
it is and and just a singular vision of
the filmmaker I don't even think that
film it can get back to that place so I
don't think anybody else can approximate
that in the future so this movie is it
is a time capsule Jim and it is of the
90s and I don't think at any point in
the future they could remake it and I
think it's even more unremarkable than
the movies these guys have not posited
slug it out guys Tarantino himself has
said that he wanted her visit the pulp
fiction universe because he wanted to
pull more about the Vega brothers
relationship into it so he's said that
he's wanted to go back into it and it
has it in years and years with multiple
choices he hasn't because he can't not
even he can't so no one else can but
thank you bring more of the bigger
brothers relationship into it and even
now and I think of like a dream casting
a pulp fiction I can think of Rooney
Mara is like an amazing Mia I could
think of Tom Hardy as a fantastic butch
Coolidge it's something that if somebody
else touched on it can be remade and
fleshing that universe more and on the
Big Trouble in Little China front I
think actually it would be remade and
fantastic if Taika Waititi jumped on it
because he said he was inspired by that
movie and I think his take would be
incredible I could be right rockin my
beautiful loving amage and now that
vaporwave is such a popular aesthetic
and that synth waves of is such a
popular like kind of kind of music and
soundtrack I think that means so much
into what's really working now and like
that combined with like a Taika Waititi
reach reimagining of it would be amazing
don't you dare bring John Carpenter's
core into this
there's something interesting about the
idea of remaking a Quinton Tarantino
piece like pulp fiction which is already
a remix of movies that inspired him I
think there's almost like a pay it
forward you could do with a remix of
remix and remake of Pulp Fiction where
it's like okay well now how has the
genre evolved what movies are going to
influence that sort of Rashomon crime
story now who is who is the person he's
gonna pluck out of its obscurity at
you're telling us we should mash it up
with the movie pay it forward under
somebody can think that but again it has
it's not going to be done watch let's
let's all get old and see who's right
and I know that pulp fiction will be
Spamalot already exists and in the case
of Vanessa's argument a remake a
reasonable one that won awards and is
pretty good I guess has already been
remade of that and and on your front a
lot of movies have tried to do the synth
Wave VAP way wonder what was that word
[Music]
yes it was used in a recent movie Mandy
who had sort of a dreamy
you know since whatever the bottom line
is this I understand these aesthetics
are popular but BICS I'm a little China
I mean Raiden is already in the Mortal
Kombat games that a big part of that
movie has been remixed and done for to
my mind better in a giant pop culture
genre video games are a genre but I
think that's the I think that's the key
is when you try to remake something
you're gonna try to remake it better and
that's that's the trap of trying to do
something like a big trouble little
China is looking at these like ragtag
we're obviously on a string rediculous
action scene for two guys just jump at
each other three times like this and go
how can we make that better how can we
make it cooler like that that's the trap
that's not responsive you that's why you
shouldn't remake that movie I think with
the guys who did the raid read the read
did that did that script over again they
did almost a shot by shot B by beat but
made the fighting better I go watch that
in a minute
I know that's a dope action movie that's
not this weird mix of like
tongue-in-cheek action it's such a thin
like thin wire to walk just that weird
self-awareness the movie had without
actually outright when we get well
fiction would look like a student film
straight which no educated which Pulp
Fiction kind of does to that's sort of
the cool grimy charm of it with with
Monty Python and the Holy Grail there's
a lot of retellings of the King Arthur
story and there's there's something cool
to me too about like what would the
mighty boosh do to retell Monty Python
and the Holy Grail or what would you
peel or like modern kind watch cantorial
do that you'll do Monty Monty bulb
fiction cuz I feel like the thing about
Big Trouble in Little China like you
said is that it's an echo of a criticism
of current big blockbuster movies and we
have been in the biggest span of
blockbuster movies that we've seen in a
long time with superhero movies with
robot movies with big-ticket movies and
I think it's a good call to criticism
but I don't think American comedy is in
a place right now where it can do that
American comedy for the past like
several years has just been we set up
three cameras so that will Ferrell can
riff like it doesn't have a feel I'm
positive this at the cameras comedy
right they got proper British
performers and and did a Spamalot slash
you know Monty Python's win the Holy
Grail type of thing I think it could
work I think it could be nice is it is
overseen by one of the month MP you know
what happened first of all they're not
gonna oversee it they're tired as hell
and they basically
go on tour as it is and second of all if
like if it was done by an American it's
gonna be thirty minutes too long in
three camera like you were pointing out
of American comedies now if it's done by
a British person we're gonna be stuck
with Ricky Gervais just being like oh
I'm to Kufa Mitsuba Zuma like if you
earnest and goofy look what happened if
you remade pole fiction right now let's
just talk about it you've got a bunch of
edge lure to want to do the dudette
Edward storage stuff and whether you
make I think you know with a lot more
boxing and you said putting more talent
into a big trouble a little China movie
you know the rock is a great talented
guy but it's you know the guy that's
attached to it that's not an untalented
worst-case-scenario person but you had
that line may the wings of Liberty never
lose a feather while Jack burns got like
oh well no this is the cheers he hasn't
been kissed on the cheek yet but you
know the with the feathering mullet and
all the guys behind him slowly getting
stoned by this by this potion and
they're just for it's ridiculous bravado
and I Joe we listen to your final
thoughts I just see that modern
blockbuster as like a oh man it's an
intense zoom on the rock and he's like
may the wings of Liberty never lose a
feather and he means that and they just
completely miss the point of this movie
that it was like just the anti
blockbuster whereas I do think you can
you can you can riff now you can on pulp
fiction I think there's been enough time
because it's almost a commentary on the
crime movies that came before it and
inspired it and I think enough time has
passed that you can now look at that
again you know we've had a gamut of
crime stories that a guy like Quentin a
Quentin Tarantino type could now riff on
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels the
remake of The Departed you know all the
way up to a lot of the sort of gritty
really micro budget stuff that's coming
out right now and and you could do like
a solid updated remake of Pulp Fiction
there and I you know I think if you if
you gave the plot outline and the reins
to to some of the cooler up-and-coming
comedy groups working and said hey tell
your Monty Python and the Holy Grail
story remake this the way you want to do
it I think someone like the birthday
boys or white women from UCB or
something like that could really
that out of the park Thank You Joestar
Vanessa final thoughts please I could
see Martin McDonagh and knocking out an
amazing Pulp Fiction
I can see Tyga ytt doing an incredible
Big Trouble in Little China I cannot see
someone especially a large group that
would be attached to this project and
have the same kind of chemistry and
familiarity that the original Monty
Python group had it's it was lightning
in a bottle
it was inventive there's absolutely no
filler in that movie most comedies now
so much filler it goes on way too long
Monty Python is as goofy and irreverent
and as long as it needs to be and I
don't think we're gonna get that now
Thank You Vanessa ed Grier well I mean I
would just like to reiterate that they
have remade the Holy Grail a Spamalot
and it was good and I didn't have all
the I don't know that I had all the
original people but I doubt it and it
was good they did that and again I will
state that the purpose of remaking
especially an action movie a movie with
that much action which big trouble a
little China qualifies as an action
movie the point of an action movie are
remaking one is to make the action
better and I posit with no rebuke that
they could certainly make the action
better and people would love to watch
that whereas again this concept that you
can get a bunch of ragtag mumblecore
filmmakers together and do pulp fiction
over again it's utterly laughable it's
so laughable the reason why those groups
of mobile core bums exists but they're
super pulp with their super pop culture
ass dialogue all of whom have they exist
because they were birthed from Quentin
Tarantino these these are copies of a
copy of a copy of a copy there's no more
toner left with these guys and he
created a sub-genre from his pitcher
hip-hop remix it up all these genres in
his movies he made these pop culture
kids that you're talking about could
so-called remake Pulp Fiction
no they couldn't cuz they're a copy of a
copy of a copy it would be very apparent
if you ever saw that movie Pulp Fiction
cannot be remade that movie has been
remade in this movie give the dudes on
the raid on that movie
could be we made this movie cannot be
remained BAM there you have it okay
again apparently I had not a fan of Noah
Baumbach Billy biz did you look anything
up this time around wow you're really
bringing the salt Joe mentioned at the
top with the Dwayne the rock Johnson's
vomit with a Big Trouble in Little China
this is from Hyrum Garcia he's the CEO
of seven bucks productions he said the
idea is not to actually remake Big
Trouble in Little China
you can't remake a classic like that
that's a direct quote also tricky
Tarantino was looking to do a prequel or
a sequel to Pulp Fiction the Vega
brothers as you mentioned but John
Travolta just unfortunately aged out of
the role and also you are correct
ed Spamalot is an adaptation of Monty
Python and the Holy Grail and there's a
film adaptation in the works with
Benedict Cumberbatch Peter Dinklage and
Tiffany Haddish which should start
filming early 2019 go all right please
section tell us what your thoughts tell
us your thoughts on the round please I
Vanessa you did a great job but I I
think that Spamalot thing just knocked
you right out for me I mean the remake
does exist and it is successful and
people do like it and they are making it
so to me it came down to Joe and Edie
both great arguments what shouldn't be
remade I I think I think ed made some
really strong arguments for me that Pulp
Fiction was kind of of its time and
everything else is just a copy of a copy
so by a hair I'm gonna go with that on
this one all right we got a hair oh boy
yeah great arguments all around I Billy
just took the words right out of my
mouth as far as yes Spamalot yet it
turned the rest of what you were saying
into idle chatter
drink when I steal punch okay and so
yeah came down to Joe and Edie for me
and man right down the line there
there's so many good points but I think
they they're also good digs against them
I really liked Joe's argument of because
we think Quentin Tarantino like kind of
remade the wheel with Pulp Fiction but
there was Rashomon there's also a great
crime film from the 50s that Jo
dimension called the killing which
played with that time construction but I
think Joe really had some great points
about revisiting but I thought gently
hit Joe hard with the Taika Waititi
anything in that guy's hands with that
kind of just levity and fun and action I
think could be really great but yeah
it's you know what for me just as far as
the commentary and losing that in the
reproduction the commentary on the
action genre that Joe was talking about
that the better effects I don't know it
might lose some of the message on the
core I'm gonna go with Joe on this one
and send it to Danielle to get the
people's vote all right well the people
with 50% Monty Python and the Holy Grail
31% for pope fiction and 17% for Big
Trouble in Little China okay it's a wash
this is crazy it's a three-way tie you
know what that means maybe a don't and
I'll tell you right now that means we go
to Danielle Radford to give her opinion
to decide this round this is a great
woman in sport I do have to agree that
the Spamalot thing not too Monty Python
right out as disappointing as it is I
have got to go with big trouble little
China
and Joe star on the board now looking
over to some of the responses a lot of
y'all back to the future clerks Fight
Club the room so many of you decided to
Kevin Smith this and go with movies that
shouldn't be remade like Oh ww2 war
propaganda like ever
you know stuff where it's like haha I'm
a Garak Oh now shy chachi
law 96 I'm guessing that's chachi 186
says singing in the rain not only would
it be very difficult to modernize which
would be the only way to remake it
that won't be a frame-by-frame reshoot
as there's no change to cinema as big as
the silent to talking pictures move that
would slow the overall plot and now
whether you agree or you disagree I
think that's a great point for
discussion so I wanted to bring that up
so y'all get in Rachel's mentions and
talk about it that's a great it's a
great its traditional live-action to
mocap suits is the remake or what are
the theaters where that's where the the
seats shake yeah regular for me that's
as big um yeah that's a great point
singing in the rain what a classical
Minnie
absolutely alright so we are tied
one-one Joe and Vanessa and Grier
looking to get on the board let's move
to question number three call the cops
thank you for my pen earlier see I help
the enemy okay I know we got some
wrestling fans in the house so the
trailer for fighting with my family just
dropped and we're going to ask you what
is the best movie starring or featuring
a professional wrestler
what is it alright and we're gonna start
with hair number three Vanessa I'm gonna
go with Jumanji - welcome to the jungle
choice like as like joe said before the
rock is a fantastic actor we've got
we've watched this man grow from the CGI
of the Scorpion King to being able to
play a lead character who inside doesn't
feel like a lead character cuz he's a
teenage boy that's been transported to
the world of the lead character that is
some dynamic acting because he portrays
the exact like unsure feeling of a
teenager who just woke up with abs that
look like corn like it also it's a movie
that in itself by all accounts shouldn't
have been good and actually was
fantastic it was a remake that did
astoundingly well and not only that he's
not like in an ensemble he's the lead so
right on okay Vanessa going with the
rock and Jumanji around the horn ahead
edie words letters the class
[Music]
that under several heads all right now
okay guys guys we're in a crisis yes
we're in a googol crisis get aside of it
thank you thank you mrs. Harker aspects
okay now look this question is what is
the best movie starring or featuring a
professional wrestler the answer to that
question is guardians of the galaxy
because my main man Batista plays Drax
the destroyer the tattooed man the buff
dude of space
I don't know how knife wielding dude in
space anyway he's great he's great his
performance is great
he imbues a lot of heart and a certain
sort of magic to his character we care
about his strife and the fact that he's
one of these people who can't deal with
his feelings either by you know his a
you know the people that he comes from
don't really deal with their feelings in
that way but his performance is really
great and again if it was Best
Performance by a wrestler I think his
acting job might be easier than homeboy
the rock but it's not its best movie
starring or featuring a wrestler and
Gardens of the galaxy gosh Blockbuster
when the director gets fired there's
protests all over the place that's how
good he is at doing these characters in
this particular way it came out of
nowhere and showed us that Marvel could
be just truly flat-out comedic and still
work and still have adventure elements
it is a great triumphant motion picture
that was in development for like more
than 10 years I think and it's just it's
a triumph and he is great in it as a
wrestler in the greatest movie to star
or feature a wrestler Karnes a galaxy
thank you sir let's head on over to
how I picked a movie well first of all
I'd like to say in spirit of this
question happy birthday to the Macho Man
Randy Savage
the late great mmm Macho Man Randy
Savage
yeah let's snap into this question you
guys yes good good how I picked a movie
that unequivocally proves that politics
and social issues have nothing to do
with with films and that's they live
just coincidentally this will not affect
my judging I am wearing a veil is how
I'm gonna see you remove the shirt for
the duration run out and just go blazer
no shirt all right blazer and bare chest
our direction of the round this is how
we keep things fair process I appreciate
it yeah no absolutely all right
skins - great all right I am completely
impartial great moment in sports
unprecedented all right Joe continue
this is not necessarily John Carpenter's
most popular movie I do think it's it's
I do think it's one of his best and
definitely is most important this stars
rowdy roddy piper in an under looked as
a wrestler and under looked as an actor
i think he would have really blown up
had he not done so many drugs but
between this and he'll comes Frogtown
amazing amazing actor this is a great
movie it's a response to John
Carpenter's distaste of Reaganomics and
the the materialism of the 80s and sort
of the feeling of waking up in a country
that you don't feel like you belong to
anymore it hits political issues just
really broadly you know the guy puts on
the sunglasses and all the sudden he
sees say the system is doing all these
specific things to keep you down the
rich are getting richer while the poor
are getting poorer hey money's your god
don't use your imagination just have sex
with each other get married and have
kids you start seeing these things
I think this is a this is a hard movie
to make because this isn't just a guy
that sees you know society sort of
crumbling around him this is a movie
about a guy who then says okay and picks
up a shotgun and fights back and Chili's
up at the top of the building to sort of
pull down this weird alien satellite
this is a guy who sort of looks in the
face of a country that he's scared of
and doesn't recognize anymore and says
I'm here to chew bubblegum and kick ass
and I'm a lot of bubblegum and I think
that's a that's a that's a that's a
movie that makes people a little
uncomfortable and makes people nervous
the sort of like armed rogue that's
gonna step up and system be damned he
doesn't believe in America anymore he's
gonna he's become disillusioned and he's
gonna fix things the only way he knows
how it features one of the great fight
scenes of all time in the alley when
he's trying his buddy to put the the
sunglasses on it's a five and a half
minute long fight scene I think and John
Carpenter loved the whole thing so much
they just put the whole thing in it one
liners out out the ass I think rowdy
roddy piper in this movie makes Bruce
Campbell's ash look like a guy who is
not good at one-liners for lack you're
just distracting me Howard
alright well got to be impartial fight
it out y'all okay okay okay okay I
always I always wait okay okay Leo gets
okay no but
that's weird darkness of the galaxy the
galaxy is without a doubt the best of
these movies and I think that's where we
need to start and I do believe that it's
a fight it's a fight off a rowdy was
good okay that was an important movie
but not necessarily great I think the
rock did have a great performance but I
stacked it up against Batista as Drax
any old day of the week because if Drax
is if Drax is the type of one note that
denotes that he can't act half the
movies ruined because a lot of it is
paid those from him have his family
killed in his hatred of Thanos and
hatred of Ronan the accuser so much he's
willing to put them in danger several
times to try to exact this revenge if he
doesn't do a good acting job I think
that that whole mechanism falls apart
and regards a galaxy made more money and
got a better critical reception than you
our movie ok first of all Drax could
have been played by Vin Diesel twice and
they just wouldn't have had to pay
double the paycheck it's not that hard
of a role second of all guardians of the
galaxy had Marvel had Marvel behind it
when it came to promotion everything was
stacked up against Jumanji - welcome to
the jungle because not only is it a
remake is a remake of a beloved
childhood movie a remake of a movie with
Robin Williams in it which classically
does not work and it went up against a
lot of other movies that summer and did
better than all of them
it actually was really beloved by
credits because it bought your old faves
out it gave us Jack Black in a way that
we haven't seen us seen him in a long
time
it gave us just enough Kevin Hart before
he got irritating which not a ton of
movies know how to do that Alec and also
it uses lead actors better who only had
like a few monotone weird English accent
lines in guardians of the galaxy and not
only that one of the best rock
performances I've ever seen and some of
the best sight gags I've ever seen and
it took the idea of what like people
that grew up with gaming now and gave it
to us in that same really good feeling
that people got with Jumanji and board
games it was that beautiful love letter
to kids that played video games growing
up and thought about what it would be
like to be in one I think my big issue
with guardians of the galaxy is it's
at that point I feel like everyone was
like oh it really broke the model mold
but I mean it's it added a soundtrack to
the marble mold it's still it's still a
sassy you know the the sassy guy in the
lead that that's snarky and quits
blowing on it smacking sound track
slander shall not stand this is
ridiculous it's still you know the sky
beam is a ship instead of a beam but
it's still ultimately like a third act
up well they got to stop the sky beam
until these people can do the thing so
that the thing doesn't happen to the
planet it can kick a satellite off a
roof that's that's way cooler than what
happened very different guardians is in
the first movie to have a good superhero
soundtrack Batman is right there we had
prints on it really bad dance not the
first one I do it's in the soundtrack
and my arguments at all that was I'm
just rebutting those guys guarding I
think that's the appeal of guardians is
silly the dialogue is great the
characterization of Drax is great and
he's a very good actor in I think movie
I think guardians of the galaxy is a
very well-written script and a very
standard Lee executed summer blockbuster
whereas they live uses charisma and
personality out of every three the
Galaxy guardians of galaxy has more
charisma and as the pinky toe than all
of they live I'm sorry there's a reason
why it was received the way it was oh
yes it had Marvel behind it but it
looked behind beyond even Marvel's
expectation much like black panther but
for different reasons obviously or maybe
not obviously well being well made
funnily enough will get you a bunch of
money whether you're supported by Disney
or no and and the fact that it was a
straight-up comedy with action elements
that was a first that was before ant-man
right the Marvel is the first action
comedy comedy with action elements
that's what I said comedy with action
elements and you know that that's what
that movie is
fine near it and Marvel movies weren't
doing that though maybe another Marvel
movie besides a man that could be
conceived of as a funny first hilarious
that was cracking a funny character for
a funny movie let's shift gears here
Vanessa griten roll it into the final
thoughts one of the big things that I
have to say is I feel like the nostalgic
soundtrack and the fact that it's a
little bit more quick here might lend
itself to guardians of the galaxy but
also if we're thinking about a wrestler
and a standout performance in addition
to a good movie you get both of that out
of Jumanji you don't really get both
with the other pics you get both of that
with this and this was a movie that
against all odds not only failed was
fantastic nothing made me laugh as hard
as Kevin Hart's weakness being cake
making him explode like it it's such a
love letter to every it's it's The
Breakfast Club meets like falling into a
videogame I it's it's it's a movie that
triumphs despite everything being
against it Thank You Vanessa around the
horn to Ed I mean half of the arguments
placed against my movie are superficial
stuff like the soundtrack and and oh it
had also it also had bright colors and
flashing lights did that make the babies
come out I don't know man it's it's a
really great movie despite all it
despite all these things these are a
cultural mall to the greatness of my
movie and I would argue that Drax is at
the center of some of what makes this
movie work and unfortunately again it is
not us battling out what is the best
wrestler performance and a damn movie
we're arguing the best movie starring or
featuring a wrestler and my movie is
better than freaking Jumanji even though
Jumanji was surprisingly good best dance
fight in the woods I ever saw and it's
better than they live even though they
live is one of my favorite movies and it
really hits me in the heart as far as
like its messages but you know you want
a message
have a plant pamphlet pamphlets are from
messages movies are for making money and
being fun and my movie made more money
and had more fun than either one of
these movies factually check me baby
fact check that that's it thank said Joe
final thoughts rich box office argument
is the home of a poor argument I think
you know guardians of the galaxy is a
great movie it is also a made by and and
covered in the fingerprints of a John
Carpenter obsessed padawan whereas they
live is the real deal Jedi Master who
has crafted this really really cool
period piece this guardians is sort of
flashy Marvel posing as a b-movie as a
strong b-movie and I mean b-movie and
with every compliment in the world
whereas they live is just full-on this
is a be ass movie this is a good cult
classic great movie top to bottom it's
incredibly paced the score is awesome
it's just this weird driving Western
score there's this building sense of
dread as the world sort of starts to
close in on nada or unnamed person
whichever you want to call them more and
more it's it's a movie about optimism
and persistence in the face of sort of a
hopeless you know outcome and I think it
performance wise Roger I brought rowdy
roddy piper really drives that home the
actions great you believe in him as this
gruff action star and I just think
emotionally you're more invested than in
guardians of the galaxy and in Jumanji
you know Jumanji sort of a fun riff on
videogames and it's fun and light and
fluffy but I think you get a really a
more balanced meal what they live where
there's laughs there's shock moments
there's really cool fight scenes and and
then beyond the cake there's a little
more of a meal to dig into BAM okay that
is our round Billy biz factuality
yeah
by the way ed you were looking for a
nickname for Drax in the very beginning
it's Drax the destroyer that I said that
and then I made up some more offered it
also like Vanessa many people were very
upset that you said Jumanji was a summer
movie it came out in December of 2017
not that it makes any difference but it
is 85 degrees in December here tell me
again your claim was that guardians of
the galaxy was the highest-grossing of
the three was that what you had asked me
to look up no they live only 13 million
but I don't believe it had an
international distribution and now
guardians the Galaxy at 773 million
worldwide Jumanji 962 almost crossing
well as just I said period
okay so Wow three very different choices
and fun arguments across the board
compelling arguments across the board
but the listen I impartiality has a
price
sorry to make this show nc-17 and lose
our YouTube I don't know whatever okay
so this was yeah great points across the
board Vanessa I feel like you loomed a
little too heavily into the rocks
performance as opposed to the movie as a
whole you sold the movie as well but
there was so much of your argument given
to the rock which is great and it's it
drives the movie but as far as best
movie Edie I felt like you were you hit
Guardians as well as far as being a good
movie but in general terms like you kept
saying it's the best movie it's a great
movie I feel like Joe broke down the
specifics as far as action theme music
vision so yeah impartiality impartial II
I'm going with Joe Billy yeah look with
all those pics and I really thought this
was yours to lose and it was Joe also
for all the reasons you just said right
on all right Joe star takes it I'm gonna
put my shirt back on
meanwhile Danielle take us through the
poll etc Wow
56% guardians of the galaxy 24 percent
they live 18 percent Jumanji welcome to
the jungle things we were seeing online
a lot of Princess Bride why didn't they
pick Princess Bride it's peanuts man a
lot of how thirst a lot more of you like
ready to rumble that I thought it did
give us to be seated
David Arquette I get it
something really really fun let me see
if I can find it at the underscore v
underscore turtle says oh come on that's
too easy best movie to feature
professional wrestler is Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles to see Kevin Nash is super
straighter also speaking of big sexy no
love for Magic Mike - yo huh oh yeah
that the Magic Mike films are
surprisingly good also what about
no-holds-barred smell if you haven't
seen the whole token the whole Cogan
movie no-holds-barred
so that means going into the speed round
it's going to be a Vanessa griten and
Joestar Ed Greer man no you did that
[Applause]
the name this meme the love of a jobber
and this is unfamiliar territory for
you're not making it to the speed around
because you you always you always bring
the pain
but today the pain brought you before we
go I have a little message from Percival
Percival would you want to say I have my
shout out of the week go ahead and give
it Percival I want to give a shout out
to a member of our nation Mike stealth
Delaney hoot
all right thanks first of all for the
shout out of the week to Owl nation all
right mr. Rogers neighborhood yes it out
so good shirt office just mr. Rogers
always put another shirt on that's
exactly our friendly neighborhood man
keeps the shirt off I just like that you
couldn't even see his lips moving when
he did it right
that was the cell phone oh I am a
restaurant-quality ventriloquist okay it
is to one Joestar let's go and again the
speed round
I'm going to ask the question shout out
your answers then the first person to
speak will elaborate first you'll each
get 20 seconds 20 seconds and then
rebuttals 10 seconds 10 seconds it's 2-1
Joe the first player to four points wins
right y'all ready for this all right in
honor of the late great Stan Lee we lost
a great one this week one of the Great's
all-time great which of his beloved
characters has starred in the overall
best movies which Stan Lee character has
starred in the overall best movies Oh
Rocket Raccoon Captain America
rock and red rocket racoon Captain
America alright we heard Rocket Raccoon
first just so they don't kill us
yeah can we check their bus stand
characters Captain America I just don't
want us to die okay we'll pick go ahead
we'll give you one more shot here
Vanessa
the good news is it's everyone else I
know it's just about picking it all
right I'm uh I'm gonna go with Iron Man
all right
Oh Civil War Civil War II there we go
okay so so we heard so uh we heard from
Vanessa since you spoke first
well she the answer second now Danielle
who should go first
i'ma say Vanessa all right Vanessa well
hold on yeah we have another problem yes
Captain America was created by Joe Simon
and Jack Kirby oh [ __ ] you're right oh
wow oh man this question is all
topsy-turvy here we did not plan this
very well okay spider-man spider-man
okay 20 seconds begins whenever you
speak Vanessa already Iron Man is the
movie that kick-started all of the
Marvel Universe that we know now it's
the one that started the summer of the
superhero and not just that stark tech
is in every single movie without having
to be in it he's in every single movie
not only is he in the spider-man movie
in a phenomenal like weird pseudo daddy
role but also he's the one that sparked
the civil war he's in all of the best
ones inadvertently just by his
technology being there Oh
dinner's ready
I think working backwards homecoming is
a fantastic spider-man movie one of the
best of the current incarnation of the
MCU the first two Tobey Maguire
spider-man's phenomenal the second
spider-man is one of the best superhero
movie sequels of all time Andrew
Garfield gave a great performance and in
some rough movies Ironman one is great
Iron Man 2 is bad Iron Man 3 ends
disappointingly after they ruined the
twist and Avengers 2 is bad that's a lot
of bad Iron Man movies we live in a
universe where spider-man 3 exists and
not only that I don't even think Andrew
Garfield was that good of a Peter Parker
he was like - hey I'm cool and not like
he didn't embody the Peter Parker that
only one movie I feel like did that for
me and it was homecoming and even then
Iron Man isn't it time all right I think
I get everybody yes
somehow be against all-out spider-man
three is still a better movie than Iron
Man 2 it's at least as coherent from top
to bottom whereas Iron Man just starts
to fall apart it's weird but at least
it's well paced and and put together
well and damn you Andrew Garfield is
shaky and sad and sweaty it's like a
partnership all right now I'll say
sweaty
Daniel Radford what do you got
difficulties y'all managed to break out
some really good arguments yeah
obviously dinner's ready was not an
argument it was fantastic these were
Vanessa because of her arguments about
stark tech and how important that has
been in a wider raging universe also
sudo daddy is funny that's fair I'm also
gonna go Vanessa I just feel in the
rebuttals she liked there were more but
there was a greater fraction of the
movies to ding and she dinged them so
yeah Vanessa you just tied up this
ballgame yay are you telling me if
they're just shouting something as bad
as sometimes ok question numero dos of
the speed round vogue the fashion
magazine stirred controversy this week
by tweeting 20-18 has not been a good
year for horror
what's the best horror film of the year
thus far hereditary Mandy hereditary
Mandy we heard hereditary first 20
seconds begin Vanessa when you speak now
not only is hereditary a movie that's
objectively shot in such a beautiful way
but it's such a cool reflection of like
the general trauma movies that are
happening through 2018 and generational
trauma in a way that I haven't really
seen since Lulla early conjuring
Exorcist it's not just a good horror
movie it's objectively a phenomenal
movie and as some of the best creepiest
gory scenes I've seen in a long time
I think hereditary being good hard
depends on whether you buy that sound
too scary or not a lot of people were
just like that's an annoying sound
mandy is a full-on just no-holds-barred
descent into madness there's there's
visual Gore there's psychological horror
there's jump scares everything you want
out of a horror movie is just jam-packed
into this crazy Nic Cage thing I can't
think of anything scarier than Nic Cage
realizing that he has nothing left to
lose
manny is still as fun and as goofy as it
needs to be to sugarcoat some of the
horror a little bit hereditary sits with
you in a really terrifying long way
where you're somehow more afraid as time
passes when you think about some of
those scenes
I think sugar spine and horror Evil Dead
uses it even though Romero uses it to
tremendous success I think hereditary
focuses a lot harder on message and
theme and less on scares whereas Manny's
just like I'm scared as hell
whoo great speed round you guys
Billy biz yeah I think based on just the
arguments Joe hit back really really
hard so I'm gonna give it to Joe Joestar
one point for you shouted yeah
it's Danielle Radford talk to us um yeah
these were both really great but I have
to agree Joe's rebuts were better so I
got to go with Jeb Joe got that rebar
Joe got the point through Joe but all
right it is three to Joe that is what we
call in our movie fights game point okay
so you need this to keep her going all
right Vanessa Joe you get this you get
the game heads drawing very wonderful
picture there it's beautiful I'm gonna
buy it from him as soon as this is over
whatever it's in my pocket you can have
it okay in honor of the new Dumbo
trailer
what is the all-time saddest kids slash
family movie
Bridge to Terabithia Bridge to
Terabithia how gonna be child death Joe
my girl child death how do you fight
child death with child death okay we
heard Bridge to Terabithia first Vanessa
20 seconds begin when you speak Bridge
to Terabithia subjectively sadder
because not only did does a child like
joy in it but it's an exploration on the
way children cope with grief which we
don't really see in my girl
and also Macaulay Culkin currently makes
fun of the fact that he died in such a
cheesy manner in my girl you got a lot
of time with and I'm also gonna go with
the fact that Bridget here video movie
how I think Nicholas Cage said it best
reset by bees and Macaulay Culkin sure
died that horrible sad death it was very
very traumatic to watch and for everyone
and we're currently laughing at be deaf
it's like getting merged by a peanut at
least
to hurt when it delivers the gut-punch
it lures you in and then makes you sad
it's not obviously sad the tragedy of my
girl is you sure do like both of them
for most of the movie and then one of
them gets killed by bees and in this
particular my girl rebuttals were
Vanessa laughing it'd be death Joe
vanessa is tied up one more time a great
moment in sports you know we're going to
a question number four okay
that even made Eadie smile alright my
earrings for your drawing no trade we
show the audience that picture at the
end yeah okay awesome good man good man
thank you
alright here it is this is for the ball
game folks in honor of widow's opening
up this week Steve McClean got great
reviews
what's the all-time greatest heist movie
it is tick-tocking it don't stop gone in
60 seconds gone in 60 seconds ant-man
no one said heat I'm dying outside we
just scrap this and move on to the next
quit okay alright no we have gone in 60
seconds
we have ant-man which one is the
all-time greatest heist movie you know
know what I should all about the
arguments and let's jump into it Joestar
spoke first 20 SEC's we can we speak now
can this amazing ensemble cast led by
the incredible Nic Cage steal so many
cards I don't know sure doesn't have to
steal a shitload of cars in a certain
amount of time in order to pull off a
heist and Nic Cage and his crew really
do in a really fun ridiculous
over-the-top manner with with awesome
chases and really cool actually cool
driving sequences I am a took a heist
movie you put superhero powers into it
which is something that we already
talked about anyway when we're sitting
around drinking with their friends and
also the use of Michael Pena to
illustrate how information gets from one
person to another person and can be used
as a key linchpin in a heist operation
hasn't been done in a movie and ant-man
did that and they did it in a way that's
not only comical but it's such a quick
concise perfect way to show
man that's a lot of cars to have to
steal again I think it's crazy that gone
60 seconds is a better car heist movie
than most of the fast and furious car
heist movies the man is a heist movie
where you get a training montage it's a
heist movie where it feels like the big
heist is happening at the beginning and
then surprise it's actually an even
bigger Heights where the person you're
gonna steal from ends up becoming a
ringleader of the second operation
alright William business Patterson
Vanessa was less bad than Jones yeah bad
yeah no I gotta agree I think banessa
you know his buddy had some had some
great points you are today's movie fight
well-played nicely done and Joe came
down to three three so and it was fun
all the way but you know you you didn't
win the point in that round but you won
the point for just for giggles PA you
made me giggle a lot Hot Fuzz absolutely
good so um the nest say your first fun
yeah the whole damn thing please go
ahead and give us some shoutouts or
whatever plug some stuff what are you up
to I have a podcast called bruja that I
host with two fantastic comedians that
you should list you on the unpopped
podcast network and I just wrote some
stuff for a fandom that I'm really proud
of I just had an article about big mouth
come out that Gina Rodriguez shouted me
out for and my heart is still
palpitating from that very cool awesome
thank you for being here and congrats on
a well-fought well-earned victory
Joestar man funny and delightful all the
way through anything you want to uh what
do you want to say yeah hey do if you
love my knowledge of heist movies you
love the fact that I'm also a tabletop
role-playing dork I just finished up a
really cool horror campaign over at out
with our friends at hyper RPG on Twitch
thing that you can go back and watch and
if you like it in two weeks we're gonna
restart with a second volume and yeah
I'm all happy and joyful and bubbly all
the time here and the dark has to go
somewhere and it goes there
cool awesome that sounds like a real
good time Thank You Joestar
please show us your original piece oh
okay that's Batman and yeah
restaurant-quality is and that's that's
the affleck batman right it's a sort of
andrew robinson long chin batman kind of
like his eyes are hella off-center Jesus
Christ I'm anyway yeah it's real good um
I thank you guys for having me this is
really fun I'm grateful to be present
during a Vanessa's first win and I know
it's going to be the first of many thank
you says the happy job I was I don't
wanna be that guy I'm super full Murtagh
right yeah yeah all the people saying
this Rick this is a fun game lighten up
everybody
I had fun and defeat Joey are you mad
thank you very much right man here I'm
on every Wednesday as a firebrand jerk
distant Mountain Dew and all types of
stuff people like oh and the mountain
dew in the dark night you hate those
things well you get a lot of internet
right and also I do a podcast called the
nerve goat podcast it's not full of hot
takes like Billy's it's just regular
guys talking about the regular guys and
gals talk about their favorite fictional
character their nerd greatest of all
time and we've had a lot of screen
junkies on we're gonna have some more
we're gonna have jte on this week so
yeah please support that and it's doing
very well
yeah 30 oh five stars five stars and
please up look at my Instagram a lot of
actual good art is on there I have a
Spider Man Miles Morales and I despite a
Gwynn picture it just got 200 whole I
don't lie your Instagram straight up
thirst trap yeah
no shirt on that's also your that was
such a cool drawing and yeah absolutely
yeah Thank You ed Grier Billy bids what
you got
well shirts were taken off children
depths for a laugh dad I don't think
band's gonna leave me in charge any yeah
on Twitter Billy a patter soon
a hot takes a Billy best this week's
episode with the lovely lady to my left
that is Daniel Radford Danielle whoo
speaking of thirst traps people are
super into shirtless about how like oh
how about apps yeah no you know I've got
my patreon which I think I'm gonna mix
things up so it's been a very Russell
focused patreon but I'm starting to
realize that a lot of y'all are also
like my movie friends so normally I've
been doing kind of like a live wrestle
chat on the weekends I think I'm gonna
do where some of its wrestling and then
some of it is like a fun movie or a bad
movie or something great so if you want
to get over they're still really cheap
just come hang out on patreon um and
yeah find me on all of the stuff I'm
already at the 10k on Twitter let's get
me up to 10k on Instagram still trying
to get free flower dresses yeah yeah
let's get Danielle those dresses and
please follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at how rudnick there's gonna
be movie stuff there's gonna be a lot of
stupidity and give me some owls hoot
hoot thanks very much for watching movie
fights Thank You Billy biz for stepping
in and thank you JT e in the booth see
you next week bye bye
you